(cell phone rings)
- Hello?
- [Voiceover] Hi Quinta.
- Oh hi, Britney.
Why are you talking so weird?
- [Britney] I'm happy.
- Happy, why?
- [Britney] I'm engaged.
- [Voiceover] It's an epidemic.
- Guys, come check this out.
- It's happening to everyone.
Just look around you.
- This is pretty scary, you guys.
- This is nuts.
- This is B.S.
Not everyone is getting married, you guys.
(knock on door)
I've got it.
- What's wrong?
- It's my brother, he's engaged.
(cries)
- I'm so scared.
- He was so young.
- He hadn't even been to a strip club yet.
- I don't want to buy a wedding gift,
or an engagement gift, it's too expensive.
- [Woman in Glasses]
I'm losing my friends,
I feel like I'm going crazy, I'm so alone.
- Do you think Zach's been
acting kind of strange?
- Hold on babe, I've gotta tie my shoe.
- OK
- What is this?
No no no no, this isn't mine.
No, No! Ahhhh!
- [Zach] Are we gonna
have to do the Macarena
at the reception?
- [Man] I don't know!
- [Zach] I don't know how to do...
- [Man] Well learn it!
- Why is this happening?
(breathes heavily)
(extended beep)
- How long before it's you?
♫ Here comes the bride,
♫ all dressed in white ♫
Will you marry me?
Will you? (gasps)
(upbeat music)